en los últimos tiempos los encuentros
entre el presidente de los eeuu y los
líderes europeos se han vuelto bastante
tensos
[Música]
la cumbre de la otan celebrada a
principios de julio de 2018 ha sido
buena prueba de ello y ha dejado sobre
la mesa algunas preguntas
tiene razón donald trump cuando critica
a sus socios europeos están los países
europeos de la otan aprovechándose del
ejército de los eeuu y tal vez la más
importante de todas debería crearse un
ejército europeo atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si algo ha quedado muy claro es que a
donald trump las reuniones con los
líderes europeos no le hacen ninguna
gracia qué pereza tener que reunirse con
toda esa gente pobre trump si al menos
fueran tan divertidos como vladimir
putin o kim jong-un sería otra cosa
[Música]
en el caso amigos es que el choque entre
la administración estadounidense y la
mayoría de gobiernos europeos se
extiende a prácticamente todas las
cuestiones economía comercio inmigración
y también defensa negro members más fan
liqing perfection en mi referente la
blazer construir de toni bernette es
cuestionada en waterville maine en
waters bolsa viven criterios ens veréis
el presidente actual de estados unidos
lleva años criticando a la otan por la
supuesta falta de implicación de los
socios europeos de hecho el presidente
norteamericano ya decía cosas así hace
casi 20 años
en eeuu no tiene un interés vital en
europa sus conflictos no valen vidas
estadounidenses alejarse de europa
ahorraría millones de dólares anuales a
este país el costo de estacionar las
tropas de la otan en europa es enorme
donald trump en el año 2000 claro que un
momento no se trata sólo del inquilino
de la casa blanca lo cierto es que en
las últimas décadas algunas diferencias
entre los europeos y los estadounidenses
se han hecho muy grandes ahí está por
ejemplo el béisbol frente al fútbol era
precio por los coches con motores
gigantescos como se nota que la gasolina
es mucho más barata o también la forma
de ver las armas en todos los campos
incluido el de la defensa si el ejército
y la cuestión militar son temas muy pero
que muy destacados en la política de los
eeuu sin embargo en europa digamos que
no tanto bueno que digo no tanto ni
siquiera son temas de primera línea y
desde luego no son nada populares
tal vez por eso desde que se terminó la
guerra fría el gasto militar de los
países europeos que pertenecen a la otan
se ha desplomado en términos de pib
pasando de algo más del 3 por ciento a
menos del 15 en europa el gasto militar
no vende y esto amigos es algo que ha
enojado muchísimo a los políticos de
washington en los últimos años y ojo en
esta cuestión no hablamos sólo de donald
trump sino también de barack obama o
george bush
aquí en visual político en un vídeo
anterior ya os contamos por qué no era
tan buena idea que los países europeos
gastarán más dinero en armas pero pero
un momento y si en washington tuvieran
razón atentos
[Música]
y si washington tuviera razón
os hago una pregunta y como siempre no
vale mirar en google sabéis cuántos
soldados tienen en total los países
europeos de la otan pues aproximadamente
un millón ochocientos mil soldados sin
embargo de este número apenas el 30 por
ciento podrían desplegarse en caso de
conflicto y tan solo entre 50.000 y
100.000 podrían desplegarse de forma
sostenida durante un tiempo
y es que amigos en general los ejércitos
europeos tienen muchos problemas
operativos si es verdad gastan mucho
dinero pero digamos que a sus gobiernos
a la mayoría de ellos no les importa
mucho el resultado podemos por ejemplo
echar un vistazo al caso de alemania un
país que en 2017 tuvo un presupuesto
militar de aproximadamente 45 mil
millones de dólares es decir es uno de
los 10 países del mundo con más
presupuesto militar
pues bien a pesar de ser uno de los
países con mayor presupuesto militar de
todo el mundo hace un par de años un
estudio de la consultora mckinsey reveló
que cerca del 60% del 60% de los aviones
de combate eurofighter y tornado de
alemania así como el 80% de sus
helicópteros más modernos no estaban
preparados para el combate por falta de
mantenimiento actualizaciones
suministros etcétera etcétera a finales
de 2017 una investigación parlamentaria
mostró unos resultados bastante
similares ni uno solo de los submarinos
y ninguno de los catorce aviones
principales de transporte de la fuerza
aérea alemana estaban operativos ni uno
solo tal cual como lo escucháis e
incluso un documento del ministerio de
defensa alemán alertó que los soldados
no tenían suficientes chalecos
protectores ropa de invierno o tiendas
de campaña para participar en alguna
misión importante de la otan y no se
trata solo de alemania es algo
generalizado
[Música]
durante la guerra de libia a pesar de
ser un conflicto relativamente pequeño
apenas tres semanas después de comenzar
los ataques las fuerzas aéreas europeas
empezaron a quedar sin armamento de
precisión en otras palabras los
gobiernos gastan dinero en grandes
programas de armamento y en tener
contratados a muchos soldados pero luego
en el día a día digamos que todo esto
importa muy poco así es como podemos
encontrarnos noticias como esta la
legión declara la guerra sin cuartel a
la obesidad la unidad de élite de la
infantería española pone en marcha un
plan forzoso para combatir el sobrepeso
entre sus miembros pero en serio pues
espera un momento porque con todo esto
no es lo peor tal vez lo que más enfada
a los oficiales de los eeuu son las
normas las reglas con las que algunos de
los ejércitos europeos han entrado en
combate de la mano de la otan
por ejemplo en afganistán veréis muchos
gobiernos europeos no quieren asumir
ningún tipo de riesgo así
y ordenan a los mandos militares que
mantengan a sus soldados lejos del
frente en el caso de la campaña afgana
por ejemplo no son extraños los
testimonios de soldados estadounidenses
que cuentan como incluso se les negó
evacuación médica por parte de los
europeos porque estaban en una zona de
combate atentos
afganistán año 2008 regresábamos de una
misión cuando un cohete impactó contra
el vehículo que estaba frente al mío
nuestro jambi estaba de repente siendo
atacado por fuego de ametralladora de
los 11 vehículos con los que entramos a
la zona de la emboscada 4 quedaron
inoperativos y un quinto fue destruido
uno de nuestros chicos había muerto y
una docena estaban heridos estábamos a
seis horas en coche de nuestra base
estaba oscureciendo y los talibanes
continuaban atacando nos cuando llamamos
para pedir una evacuación médica nos
preguntaron si la zona de aterrizaje aún
estaba caliente dijimos que si nos
estaban atacando en ese momento una voz
con acento extranjero me dijo que sus
reglas les impedían prestarnos
asistencia me preguntó si podríamos
asegurar la zona de aterrizaje o si nos
podríamos trasladar los minutos pasaron
a ser horas y los talibanes siguieron
disparando contra nosotros entonces de
la nada apareció una voz en nuestra
radio era una voz estadounidense un par
de helicópteros blackhawk en una misión
totalmente distinta habían escuchado
nuestra llamada de auxilio
los pilotos se desviaron de inmediato en
15 minutos aterrizaron y nuestros
heridos fueron evacuados
y nuestros superiores nos dijeron que el
país de la otan que en ese momento era
responsable de las evacuaciones médicas
tenía la regla de no intervenir en zonas
aún calientes estábamos furiosos el jet
ackermann veterano que sirvió en
afganistán en el cuerpo de operaciones
especiales de los marines un momento muy
importante tan solo en afganistán cerca
de 900 soldados europeos han perdido la
vida
estamos hablando de órdenes políticas
que no se dan en todos los casos pero
que son habituales y no no es una
cuestión de dinero sino fundamentalmente
de compromiso los países europeos de la
otan gastan cada año más de 260.000
millones de dólares
es decir juntos tienen el segundo mayor
presupuesto militar tras eeuu
[Música]
a pesar de ello en washington quieren
que los países europeos de la otan
eleven sustancialmente su gasto militar
y es ahí donde aparece la cifra mágica
del 2% del pib
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el mito del 2%
lo ha dejado muy claro en la última
cumbre de la otan
donald trump está furioso según dice la
inmensa mayoría de los países de la
alianza atlántica están retrasados en el
pago de sus cuotas fijaos
muchos países en la otan que se espera
que nosotros defendamos no sólo están
por debajo de su compromiso actual del 2
por ciento que es bajo sino que también
están atrasados desde hace muchos años
en pagos que no se han realizado
reembolsarán a los eeuu pues una de dos
o dice estas cosas porque no tiene ni
idea o simplemente lo dice porque quiere
sacar tajada electoral engañando claro a
los votantes porque seamos claros todo
esto de los pagos atrasados no tienen ni
pies ni cabeza
el 2% es un objetivo de gasto militar de
cada país para su propio ejército no
tiene nada que ver con pagos a la otan
ni nada por el estilo es decir que un
país gaste menos no quiere decir que
deba nada ni a la otan ni a eeuu ni a
nadie pero bien el caso es que en 2014
tras mucha presión
barack obama logró el compromiso de los
países europeos de la otan de que
incrementarían sustancialmente su
presupuesto militar hasta rozar el 2 por
ciento sobre el pib en el año 2024 y
precisamente debido a ese compromiso
europa es ojo la región del mundo donde
más se está incrementando el gasto
militar fijaos
[Aplausos]
si ya os lo podéis imaginar luego tanto
trump como sobre todos sus partidarios
dirán que todo esto es gracias a él y a
sus habilidades para negociar sin
embargo aunque se incrementa el gasto
militar probablemente no cambie nada
primero esta cifra del 2% es una cifra
aleatoria a la que se podría llegar
simplemente elevando los salarios de los
militares o haciendo trampas contables
de todo tipo
grecia por ejemplo es uno de los pocos
países que cumplen gasta el 2 36 por
ciento de su pib pero gran parte de ese
presupuesto se destina a pagar las
pensiones de los militares e incluso la
mayor parte de su inversión en equipo
militar se orienta a la defensa contra
turquía otro país miembro de la otan
el resultado aunque aparentemente se
cumple la regla de gasto el ejército
griego aporta poco o nada a las
capacidades de la organización pero es
que incluso aunque se utilizará todo ese
dinero para mejorar realmente los
ejércitos y desde luego sin un
compromiso político es algo que no va a
ocurrir tampoco se conseguiría gran cosa
los países europeos seguirán dependiendo
de eeuu para el despliegue de sus
fuerzas porque país a país no podrían
permitirse mantener capacidades de
despliegue e inteligencia y
aprovisionamiento a nivel mundial y por
supuesto como en europa las operaciones
militares no son algo popular ni el
compromiso político ni las reglas para
entrar en combate cambiarían es decir si
tendríamos ejércitos más grandes pero a
la hora de la verdad con unas carencias
muy similares pero es que además vamos a
ver las funciones esenciales que pueden
realizar las fuerzas armadas son
fundamentalmente cuatro disuasión
intervención y despliegue ocupación y
por último ciberseguridad pues para
ninguna de esas tareas el presupuesto
actual de los países europeos supone una
traba para combatir el terrorismo para
desplegarse rápidamente en algún lugar
del mundo y enfrentar alguna situación
especial no hace falta tener uno y otro
y otro portaaviones es decir fuerzas
redundantes
es mucho más importante tener la
capacidad de desplegarse rápidamente y
ser capaz de gestionar un conflicto ahí
están por ejemplo las últimas guerras de
eeuu y la propia otan afganistán irak y
libia en todas ellas la victoria militar
fue sencilla pero la posguerra un
desastre absoluto haber contado con
fuerzas preparadas para gestionar los
conflictos locales las instituciones de
los diferentes países para entrenar a
las fuerzas nacionales no sólo militares
sino también por ejemplo a los cuerpos
de policía o para poner en marcha
juzgados prisiones o centrales
eléctricas hubiera sido probablemente
mucho pero que mucho más útil si al fin
y al cabo amigos para enfrentarse a un
conflicto hace falta hacer muchas cosas
y no todo es lo mismo las amenazas a las
que nos enfrentamos hoy no necesitan de
más portaaviones o más cazabombarderos
sino sobre todo de más agilidad europa
no necesita gastar más ya gasta
muchísimo necesita gastar
mejor y es ahí donde aparece la idea del
ejército europeo
pescó un ejército europeo en diciembre
de 2017 la unión europea lanzó el
programa pescó en castellano cooperación
estructurada permanente en materia de
defensa
el objetivo coordinar a los países que
participan en el programa en cuanto a
seguridad adquisición de material bélico
y operaciones conjuntas de defensa y paz
es decir en otras palabras empezar a
integrar las diferentes fuerzas armadas
el programa todavía se encuentra en una
fase muy incipiente y no contempla como
un equivalente a un ejército europeo sin
embargo esta podría ser la mejor
solución a todos los problemas los 25
países que integran el programa pesco
integrando sus ejércitos sus compras de
armamento sus entrenamientos e incluso
compartiendo recursos militares podrían
suponer que europa aún gastando menos
tuviera un ejército moderno bien
equipado y con una gran capacidad de
despliegue
al fin y al cabo que un país como españa
se gaste una fortuna en comprar tanques
leopard 2 que en la práctica por falta
de medios para desplegarlos sólo sirven
para defenderse de un hipotético ataque
y de portugal es un gasto totalmente
innecesario nos parecen amigos hoy los
riesgos y los retos son globales así que
creo sinceramente que europa necesita
más integración a hacer mejor las cosas
y en el marco de la otan buscar
completar a eeuu pero no gastar más casi
300 mil millones de dólares al año
tienen que ser más que suficientes pero
ahora turno para ti
crees que europa debe desarrollar su
propio ejército déjame la respuesta en
los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta y como siempre si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo dale al
botón de like y no olvides suscribirte
al canal un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]